فقط ننوه بهذا الخبر نقلا عن الجيش
الاسرائيلي فعلى صعيد العمليات العسكريه
تشهد مناطق متعدده في قطاع غزه معارك
ضاريه بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وجيش
الاحتلال على مختلف محاور التوغل وكما
نتابع في الاخبار العاجله فقد اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي مقتل ثلاثه اخرين من عناصره
هما
ضابطان وجندي خلال المعارك في قطاع غزه
وذلك بعد ان كان اعلن في وقت سابق مقتل
ضابط وجندي واصابه
43 من عسكرييه خلال الساعات ال 24 الماضيه
يرتفع بذلك عدد القتلى في صفوف الجيش
الاسرائيلي المعلن عنهم بشكل رسمي منذ بدء
التوغل البري في ال 26 من اكتوبر الماضي
الى
1667 اما العدد الاجمالي منذ عمليه طوفان
الاقصى والحرب على غزه في السابع من
اكتوبر الماضي فقد ارتفع الى
491 قتيلا بين ضابط
وجندي وكشفت اذاعه الجيش مقتل جنديين
الشهر الماضي بعد قصف دبابه اسرائيليه
مبنى في غزه تبين لاحقا
داخل بداخله قياده كتيبه
اسرائيليه